okay I have a whole theory that like the
church is actually like a homemaker and
like it's actually like a a breeding
ground for hoes and I'll tell you what
I'll tell you why okay because it's like
what they'll do is they'll have these
chastities and I remember being in high
school because I've always been me you
know I've always kind of like thought
the way I do but I was just like a young
Pearl in high school and we had this
Chastity speaker and I was thinking like
basically she went up and she said I got
ran through but then I found God you
know praise God and then the husband was
like and then the husband was like oh
yeah and I I found her after this and
like I was a virgin and I waited and she
and it's oh and I realized it was like
it's always the women who didn't wait
and I'm like oh it's like they're kind
of marketing you can be a hoe and then
find a husband like it's like a
marketing like I don't think they mean
to but I'm like oh it's like that's what
they're marketing to young women and